joining us once again on the programme
the minister responsible for the
vaccines rollout nadine zaha mr zawi
good to see you this morning um
and plenty of course to discuss about
the ongoing ongoing rollout but
let's not let the health secretary be
the only person that gets congratulated
on this program
we hit that 15 million target as the
minister minister responsible you've
clearly played a big part in that so
well done
thank you very much neil and it's an
incredible team
that has delivered that target not least
brigadier phil prosser and 101 logistics
brigade but of course the nhs the gps
the nurses the pharmacists
the volunteers the army of vaccinators
and of course the volunteers
marshaling people making sure those four
cohorts those most vulnerable people uh
uh were offered the vaccine
and uh were able to get through vaccine
sites in a smooth way as possible so
i stand on the shoulders of of heroes
and i feel in many ways
like a bit of an imposter but we we
focus on making sure now we deliver the
next target
which is we offer the vaccine to
all five to nine uh cohorts so that's um
in total we'll be at 32 million people
with the first dose and of course
the second dose this week is the first
sweet meal where
we've been able to with the supply
stabilizing
send out the schedules over the next
three weeks for people to begin
uh of course to deliver for cohort five
and six but also
to book in the second doses which will
begin in hospital hubs uh
uh in the final week of february and
then in
uh primary care and gps from the first
of march onwards
um can we then minister perhaps talk
just a little about a subject that i
know
is concerning you've you vaccine
hesitancy an interesting
piece of information that did not cross
my radar i have to admit
that some people within the the black
and minority ethnic asian minority
ethnic communities are saying that
they are concerned about taking the
vaccine because they're concerned
that it may affect fertility they're a
concern that it may affect them
if they are pregnant can you speak
directly to that and provide some some
reassurances
absolutely uh there is a tsunami of
disinformation misinformation which
we have a unit across government that is
dealing with the
uh uh technology platforms to take down
some of this fake news
uh in terms of effects on fertility it
does not
in terms of a pregnancy you can have
your vaccine
of course once you've had a discussion
with your clinician to make sure that
your own
um you know physiology allows you to do
that
it's one of the issues that simon
stevens the chief executive of the nhs
addressed last night which is
this sort of the pandemic itself and
then a pandemic of misinformation
or as i just referred to a tsunami of
misinformation
on social platforms and it's very
important that we continue
to deliver accurate information in
people's
own languages but of course in their
communities we're translating everything
into
20 languages from arabic to farsi to
hindu to
polish across the board we have to reach
those hard-to-reach groups because
although
and you've heard me say this before
vaccine positivity in the uk
so people adults saying they will take
the vaccine
is at 89 of the adult population
the 11 that are vaccine hesitant or
have questions uh skew heavily towards
uh some of the ethnic communities the
black and afro-caribbean communities the
indian and pakistani and bangladeshi
communities
and we are working with those community
leaders we've put 25 million pounds to
work
through local government and of course
most importantly i i
published the uptake strategy on
saturday
sharing data with local government the
nhs
and local government working hand in
hand to make sure we reach
those groups with the information and of
course
the access one of the things we found
neil is actually
a lot of people want easier access to be
able to go and get vaccinated
so we are assessing lots of pop-up sites
uh at least 200 new faith group
sites have come forward and we're
looking at those as well we're already
vaccinating in
the hickman center in batley that the pm
visited and of course
their bass mosque in birmingham and
cathedrals around the country
it's about access that i think we will
be our focus on that
and data sharing will hopefully get us
to the high levels of
acceptance from black and ethnic
minority communities
those those faith centers being used for
vaccination i'm sure
will advance the the campaign against
disinformation
but again a suggestion a very specific
suggestion coming from within the muslim
community
is that there are perhaps significant
numbers of people not taking
the first dose of the vaccine because
their
second dose would fall and it would fall
in ramadan now
i don't know enough about islam to say
whether or not this is something that
would be prescribed by islam but clearly
there are concerns again speak very
specifically to this community if you
can minister
yeah very much so uh neil so
of course we make um already
plans for ramadan when people are
fasting
uh and make sure that as we do uh
with your other communities uh look into
their festivals uh purim is almost upon
us for the
jewish community and of course ramadan
is something that we've got to make sure
that the system adjusts to be able to
deal with that
but faith leaders in the muslim
community have come out
very clearly whether it's the east
london mosque or the abbas
mosque in birmingham and said that
actually you have to come forward and
take your vaccine
it protects you we know that uh bamey
communities
are disproportionately impacted by this
virus so
come forward and take the first dose and
we'll make sure that
we will accommodate any issues around
ramadan or any other religious festival
to make sure that you can get your
second dose safely and in the correct
way
good to hear minister um i i wonder if
we can talk about some of the measures
that were
were introduced pretty much first in a
response to kovid 19 social distancing
and mask wearing a suggestion picked up
by our deputy political editor sam coats
you know that the scientists advising
the government are wanting to see those
measures kept in the for the
for the foreseeable future are you
minded
to see that happen i mean i suppose that
the point is that
you know people have been hearing
ministers talking about a return to
normality
for many people social distancing not
being able to hug your friends
wearing a face mask that doesn't fall
within
plenty of people's definition of of
normal
you you're absolutely right we are all
pro-social animals
um you know it's in our dna that we
want to socially interact we want to hug
our children our grandchildren
uh our our friends uh i would say this
we have to be data driven
rather than just date driven you know we
have to follow the
the evidence um from uh sage
from the scientists to make sure that
you know if
we are able to control this virus better
obviously our main
um you know our way out of this pandemic
is
our vaccination program which we are
we're making sure that we deliver
as quickly as possible protecting the
most vulnerable and then moving to the
whole of the adult population you know
we want to be able to
uh by september have offered the vaccine
to the whole of the adult population
but with that level of vaccination
which hopefully we'll see the data on uh
infection rates coming down
transmission there's some good data from
oxford but we're uh that has to be
peer-reviewed and we wait for our own
data from the
public health england uh surveys that
are being conducted
but with that surge testing
tracing and isolation and any other
measures whether it's mass squaring
or social distancing i think we have to
be driven by the data
rather than just dates uh that's that's
my message
to to uh your viewers is if we look at
the evidence
and share that evidence uh people are
are you know
able to make those decisions uh for
themselves and i think that's the right
way
to do that the prime minister will be
saying more on this on the 22nd of
february in terms of the roadmap back to
uh reopening schools hopefully on the
8th of march and then gradually
reopening our economy
but it has to be data driven evidence
driven rather than just
relying on on what we all want to see
because we're all anxious to want to get
our lives back and
our economy uh back on its feet as
quickly as possible
yeah and again this this kind of all
takes us back to to the prime minister
repeating yesterday something that he
said before the case numbers are going
to be incredibly
important in determining which measures
are relaxed and so on
i i suppose the question there is that
we are testing more than we ever have
done which is
undeniably going to register more cases
just because of that i mean if we look
back to when case numbers were low
last summer july the 4th when the pubs
reopened it was 624 cases
that we were registering with far fewer
tests
going on than there are now so i'm just
wondering what kind of level do we need
to bring it down to
before we start talking about what we're
going to be hearing you know
next monday well i think you're
you're right to look at whether it's
case numbers and
you're absolutely right to say that we
are now both in terms of capacity
at about 800 000 pcr capacity
tests a day uh and of course the level
of testing you know
we're we're almost touching that on
average a week about
six to seven hundred thousand tests uh a
day
uh per week as well as of course many
many
uh uh more uh lateral flow tests through
local government through
businesses uh uh as well as
uh people in the nhs and and in the
healthcare system having those
twice a week tests to make sure that we
remain on top of the virus but again the
prime minister's right to say
that where we are today uh in terms of
number of people in hospital
in terms of uh case numbers per day it's
still
far too high and we want to make sure we
bring that right down but i'm
you know i wouldn't want to speculate on
this
until we see more data and of course
ask those who are expert the the
scientists
the sage and of course the uh uh
chief medical officer to look at this
and to advise us accordingly
and be data driven we all want the same
thing that we want
to make sure we reopen the economy as
quickly as possible
but of course make sure that it is
sustainable that's the important thing
uh hence why we've got such a strong
vaccination
uh deployment campaign but also the
prime minister's already asked us
to think about not just this vaccination
deployment
but what will happen if we need a
booster in the autumn which we're
planning
for and of course then annual
vaccination program
uh for future years if we have to uh
deliver that if the virus be you know
has mutated to to a level where we need
vaccine variants and of course annual
uh vaccination programs all of that will
be
uh discussed in the mix and of course uh
the pm will set out
at the road map on the 22nd of february
based on the level just
just interrupt sorry to interrupt
minister but just one thing that the
prime minister did mention yes the
lateral flow
test to essentially enjoy a night out
now there are a couple of problems with
that obviously case numbers are far too
high
for mass use of lateral flow also are we
really going to be testing people
for access when there are so many false
positives
well so false negatives i should say yes
and
i got your uh point absolutely right so
i think
uh what the prime minister actually said
is it will be a combination a
combination
of the national vaccination program
becoming you know really successful
reaching that 89 of the adult population
where currently according to all the
surveys including the office for
national statistics survey
that uh you know 85 percent of the
adults say they will take the vaccine
the latest stats i saw i think from
ipsos mori said 89 said they will take
the vaccine
so what he was talking about is a world
where
we have you know the adult population
vaccinated
uh to those high levels and then rapid
testing technology
where you can get a quick test done and
then be able to use that as a way of
reopening
whether it be theaters or the rest of
the economy